foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is James page in Madrid at the
ftth council Europe meeting and I'm here
with Catherine Collins from openreach
where she is the managing director of
corporate Affairs Catherine thank you
for coming and having a little
conversation with us
um you're talking here about the UK
situation and we've just had the new
numbers published in the Panorama report
yesterday as always what they people
talk about uh the UK lagging behind but
but some good numbers in terms of
catching up fast where do you think we
are look I think we're in a really good
position as you say the numbers that
came out yesterday this morning show
what a rapid Pace we're moving at in
terms of the UK and fully fiber in the
UK look I think we all know we started
from a different position there's
historic reason why we started there
because we invested heavily in the
Superfast Network which actually has
done the UK incredibly proud you know it
ensured that we had some of the highest
penetrations of e-commerce across most
of the world actually not just Europe
and it stood us up very well during
covert but you know it got us through US
transitioning to working from home
schooling from home but we all know we
need a future-proof network that is full
fiber and we've only really been going
at this for sort of five-ish years in
the UK and we've now got to well over 40
UK coverage with open reach we hit a 10
million fttp Target just the last month
or so that's pretty much as I said from
a standing start 10 years ago and we're
building at a rate of 54 000 premises
per week just as open reach so I think
in terms of pace we're building probably
as a single operator faster than any
other operator or potentially any other
European country has ever done so we
built three million fttp premises next
year and are planning to repeat that
next year so we started from a position
where we were further behind than others
on the journey but I think we are
rapidly accelerating we'll probably
overtake quite a few countries because
we have a plan also to try and get to
those really hard Ultra rural really
difficult communities in a way that some
mothers don't so I think at some stage
hopefully you'll see us overtake really
interesting so is that part of the
strategy now where openreach is thinking
about those rural areas but it it's also
about and others have spoken about it
while we're here there's the build but
then it's also making sure we've got
people on the networks and that's
important too right yeah I think I I've
I think the challenge is how do you
fully fiber the entire UK and that's
what I want to talk about later you know
it's it's not just getting to the easy
sort of suburban urban areas it's how do
you actually get that connectivity to
absolutely everyone so that they can
make use of the networks and also so
then public services are genuinely
ubiquitous so we've always had a
commitment as open reach and I think
we're the only operator to do a balance
build so we've said we'll build in
proportion in those really hard to reach
areas as well as in the more commercial
Urban suburban and we're doing that with
our own funding and our own money so
we've built of that 10 million full
fiber footprint in the UK three million
of that is in the hardest to reach of
com area three and Our intention is to
continue to do that as you say though
the bigger challenge is you can build a
network but there's no point in having
the network unless you've got people on
it it's been I think a little bit slow
as a start to try and transition people
onto that Network partly because we have
a great super fast Network that has
worked for most people most of the time
and we know that full fiber is a
future-proof technology for things
people will want to do in the future but
currently Superfast kind of works for
most people so we are in a process of
how do you move an entire population
onto a new network which means we need
to talk more about the benefits in
particular the reliability the latency
you know the potential benefits that
people have at home in terms of how they
want to live future lives Internet of
Things connected fridges Etc but it's
it's been tricky because you have this
existing Legacy platform I do think
we're starting to crack it so again of
that 10 million platform we've got we've
now got three million customers on an
fttp product so that's a little bit
beyond 25
which is pretty good actually given
you've got this very good ubiquitous
super fast coverage and we are
definitely seeing that the isps in the
market are now making that very big
shift to really going for trying to
transition customers onto the network
and that's why we've got deals out in
the marketplace such as Equinox which
are all designed in partnership with the
isps to ensure we can migrate the
country hopefully more rapidly onto a
full fiber Network thank you for that
explanation I think it's really
interesting because having talked to
lots of people out here that there's so
many similarities with what's happening
in other nations lots of different dates
for when they've got copper uh switch
off and and thinking about how they're
managing to get their their coverage
levels up uh while you're here I suppose
it's a it's a two-part question really
in the sense of what could we learn from
what what they're doing but given the
pace of acceleration that we've got in
the UK are there things that they ought
to be learning from us too
um yeah I I think that's true I think
look the benefit of going lost
potentially in the full fiber build is
that we've been able to learn from
others so I think the one thing that we
have done and we continue to do at
events like this is learn how other
people have done the rollout and so we
as open reach have spent quite a lot of
time going around not just European
countries but sort of globally South
Korea you know other America places that
are sort of slightly further advanced in
the journey looking at the technology so
I think one of the reasons behind the
success of the UK rollout and why it's
so rapid is we've been able to take a
lot of those learnings and in particular
a lot of the Innovation and the
technology that's been developed by
others and apply it to the UK situation
now I think all countries are
fundamentally different our geography is
very very different to say a Spain or a
Portugal which is why the price points
are so different so I think it is
difficult to sort of compare like for
like when people think about the sort of
value and the pricing and the build
costs but what you can do is you can
take all that loaning and apply it to
your own situation which is what we've
done so some of the advances with
connectorized blocks and you know
broader technology and how people are
accessing MDU use for example and the
ways they're tackling that it's the same
problems we've got so we've definitely
taken all of that I think in terms of
what people can learn from us
I think what is really helpful is we
have a very stable and supportive
Regulatory and policy environment
there's still stuff we need to help us
go further and faster but actually ofcom
have done a fantastic job in creating
the wftmr which gives a really good
stable base for us as the incumbent but
also for the alternative networks to
invest and I think that regulatory
structure and the flex within it has
really allowed that acceleration over
the last year so I think for anyone to
continue the sort of pace of rollout
that we're doing that regulatory model
is worth looking at but also the way
government has set some very clear
targets around where they want to get to
in particular that rural coverage
because I think for all of us the
difficulty is not the first sort of 70
75 percent is the last bits you know
even if you don't have the geography of
Shetland and mountains in Wales you've
still got some really hard bits to reach
and stuff that's expensive so I think
looking at how the UK and the UK
government has thought about how you
tackle that is is really helpful for
others to think about how do you get
that end of The Challenge and that last
piece done
absolutely fascinating really
interesting thank you for taking us
through quite a wide range of different
topics so um really appreciate you
coming over and explaining some of that
and I hope you have a really successful
conference thank you very much great to
be here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]